la parole est maintenant à madame
virginie du vip muller pour le groupe
l'est républicain de l'assemblée
nationale vous avez la parole pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre
mais là messieurs les ministres mesdames
messieurs les parlementaires
nous avons achevé il ya quelques jours
une campagne électorale qui a donné lieu
comme il est nécessaire en démocratie à
la confrontation des opinions et des
projets notre nation a choisi emmanuel
macron est désormais notre chef d'état
et nous souhaitons unanimement sa
réussite à l'elysée car son succès sera
intimement lié à celui de la france
il succède à d'illustrés prédécesseurs
au premier rang duquel le général de
gaulle cette responsabilité langage il
est devenu le garant du bon
fonctionnement des institutions de la
vème république il incarne désormais la
république française et son histoire
le président de la république est
également le garant du respect des
droits de l'opposition
c'est un des fondements de notre pacte
démocratique
c'est la garantie de la vitalité de
notre parlement
il doit veiller à préserver cette
opposition et ses contre-pouvoirs en
résistant à toute tentation hégémonique
qui serait par nature dangereuse et
mortifère pour notre république
nous reconnaissons la légitimité que
votre majorité a acquise dans les urnes
mais aucun calcul politicien de nous ne
doit vous conduire à transiger avec les
fondamentaux de l'opposition qu'elle
émane de votre gauche ou de votre droite
je fais partie des députés qui n'était
pas donné gagnant au soir du premier
tour
pourtant je me suis battu et je suis là
devant vous la politique est bien
souvent un combat des idées et vous le
savez tous et toutes dans cette
assemblée
mais c'est aussi un espace de discussion
de propositions de construction
chacun doit pouvoir y donner son avis
et la vie de chacun doit pouvoir y être
entendu c'est là toute sa noblesse
or mercredi dernier au coeur même de
l'hémicycle les droits de l'opposition
ont fortement été mise à mal à cause
d'une manoeuvre de quelques députés
ils n'ont pas respecté le fonctionnement
et les usages de notre assemblée le
président vient de dénoncer le monde des
petits arrangements
nous venons est las de subir une triste
résurgence de ce vieux monde
ne nous voilons pas la face aucun des
questeurs élus à l'assemblée ne
représente un groupe de l'opposition
tous ont été élus avec le soutien direct
ou indirect de votre parti la république
en marche
tous ont annoncé publiquement qu'il
voterait la confiance au gouvernement
sans même attendre de connaître le
discours de politique générale du
premier ministre
en résumé le contrôle du budget et du
fonctionnement de l'assemblée devient
donc le monopole de députés favorables à
votre majorité
partant de ce constat les groupes
d'opposition se retrouve bien mal
représentés dans cette nouvelle
assemblée monsieur le premier ministre
la majorité ne doit pas choisir son
opposition
le président de la république a souhaité
moderniser la vie politique en mettant
fin aux vieilles pratiques politiciennes
comment dès lors cautionner de tels
agissements car ceux qui ne respectent
pas la divergence de point de vue des
figures ce que les français ont mis tant
d'années à construire ce qui profite du
rouleau compresseur pour écraser les
différences rabaisse la pratique
parlementaire
ceux qui refusent d'entendre le discours
contradictoires déshonore leur mandat et
je souhaiterais d'ailleurs cité paul
ricoeur particulièrement cher à emmanuel
macron on excelle en rien en tenant
compte d'autrui
une démocratie apaisée ce n'est pas une
démocratie où tout le monde est d'accord
mais une démocratie où tout le monde
s'écoute et se respecte
nous attendons de vous une volonté ferme
de construire ensemble la france de
demain en écoutant les représentants de
la nation monsieur premier ministre une
réforme de nos institutions vient de
nous être annoncé certaines de vos
propositions vont dans le bon sens et
sont profondément nécessaire car entre
l'organisation nos institutions et la
vie de la nasa
lyon il existe un lien étroit et
fondamentale nous partageons une
responsabilité commune porter la voix de
nos concitoyens apaiser le débat
démocratique
travailler ensemble au service de
l'intérêt général le groupe l'est
républicain vous suivra notamment dans
votre volonté de réduire la
prolifération législatives qui dessert
notre action nous craignons toutefois
que cette réforme institutionnelle que
vous appelez de vos voeux soulève deux
écueils majeurs d'abord qu elles
désavantagent les territoires ruraux qui
deviendraient les grands oubliés de la
représentation nationale ensuite qu'elle
affaiblit ces parlementaires et donc le
pouvoir législatif avec une dose de
proportionnelle dans les scrutins la
représentativité serait mécaniquement
entraver la proportionnelle c'est le
triomphe des partis et du centralisme
jacobin
elle ne permettra plus aux habitants
d'avoir un lien direct avec leur député
les parlementaires serait moins présent
donc moins connu et moins identifiables
c'est un recul démocratique majeur il
deviendrait aussi très compliqué de
sanctionner son député dans les urnes
car les chefs serait toujours réélu nous
refusons donc de créer une assemblée
hors sol ou des apparatchiks déconnecté
des territoires prendrait le pouvoir
méfions-nous également de la méthode de
réduction du nombre de parlementaires si
elle devait pénaliser les territoires
ruraux car supprimer les élus cela veut
dire augmenter la taille des
circonscriptions
et donc faire peser le risque d'un
éloignement avec son député
ce sera le cas surtout dans les
territoires sous peuplés cela signerait
la fin de cette relation de confiance et
de proximité que nous connaissons tous
avec nos administrés nous ne pouvons pas
laisser une partie des français au bord
du chemin
enfin prenons gars là la tentation
démagogique de limiter le nombre de
mandats dans le temps
en tant que jeune élu je comprends et je
soutiens le renouvellement des pratiques
politiques
mais tout ce qui contribue à censurer
les lecteurs dans son choix est
antidémocratique
le propre de la démocratie et de laisser
le plus de liberté possible à chaque
citoyen pour choisir son représentant et
se fait d'ailleurs pleinement confiance
à nos électeurs pour ne pas réélire un
de leurs représentants qui se serait
montrée décevante
les sirènes du renouveau compte ainsi
leurs limites à l'épreuve de la pratique
parlementaire l'hémicycle doit être
représentatif avec des élus expérimentés
qui transmettent leurs compétences aux
nouveaux arrivants car aucun élu ne
saurait être réduit à être un automate
dans une chambre d'enregistrement
nous avons des propositions fortes et
nous demandons à être entendu et pour
que la nation est un sens il faut
qu'elle soit incarnée représenté dans
toute sa diversité
monsieur le premier ministre
l'abstention a été la grande gagnante
des dernières élections
près d'un citoyen sur deux n'est pas
allé voter en juin dernier
nous devons tirer toutes les
conséquences de ce refus d'aller voter
beaucoup est à reconstruire et nous
devons agir vite notre pays a trop
souffert d' immobilisme dans cette
course en repos le progrès entraîne les
grandes nations
le courage des réformes nous a fait
cruellement défaut ces dernières années
le nombre de chômeurs n'a cessé
d'augmenter
deux millions de jeunes sont sans
formation exclues de l'emploi
nos classes moyennes ont subi des
hausses d'impôts massives nos
entreprises croulent sous les
contraintes
le budget voté par la majorité
socialiste pour 2017 a été jugé un
sincère par la cour des comptes
l'insécurité sur notre territoire a
augmenté et plusieurs attentats
terroristes ont endeuillé notre pays
cette année cent mille jeunes ont quitté
l'école sans diplôme
notre système social est en crise et
nous ne prétendons pas correctement le
vieillissement de la population
nos collectivités territoriales sont
asphyxiés et notre ruralité est en
grande souffrance
comment promettre à nos concitoyens des
lendemains qui chantent sans
entreprendre les réformes indispensables
que les français attendent de longue
date avec les républicains nous serons
au rendez vous pour des réformes
d'ampleur que nous appelons de nos voeux
depuis cinq ans nous serons au rendez
vous comme nous l'avons toujours été
pour lutter avec force contre le
terrorisme et garantir la sécurité de
nos citoyens au rendez vous également
pour une réforme économique majeure qui
libérera nos entreprises afin de lutter
efficacement contre le chômage
nous nous mobiliserons pour restaurer la
méritocratie et l'excellence française
en améliorant notre système éducatif
nous serons présents pour lutter contre
la fracture territoriale et notamment
garantir l'égalité des soins en france
nous serons au rendez vous pour rebâtir
nos pratiques politiques car la
confiance de la nation et la valeur
démocratique la plus précieuse que nous
ayons au rendez-vous aussi pour
développer le numérique nouveaux gages
de transparence pour davantage incluant
nos concitoyens dans la vie publique
nous sommes aussi mobilisés pour la
réussite de l'accord de paris garant de
l'avenir de notre planète
enfin nous serons au rendez vous pour
donner une nouvelle impulsion à l'union
européenne
l'adjectif constructif bien que très à
la mode n'est ainsi pas l'apanage de
certains députés
il nous concerne tous de manière
constante
nous avons été élu comme représentant de
la nation
comment pourrions-nous ne pas être
constructif alors oui nous serons au
rendez vous de la réforme de l'état pour
redonner à notre république
sa force d'action pour autant nous vous
l'avons dit nous refusons de vous donner
un blanc seing
nous serons nous mobiliser dans nos
assemblées respectives pour dénoncer et
combattre des réformes pénalisante pour
les français comme c'est le cas pour la
hausse massive et injuste la csg dans la
situation actuelle il n'y aurait rien de
pire que d'échouer par manque d'ambition
d'audace et finalement par manque de
responsables
été fidèle à l'esprit gaulliste nous
nous y refusons messieurs les présidents
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires
le modèle républicain reste notre socle
notre référence commune la république
c'est la promotion sociale fondée sur le
mérite et le talent elle fait de chacun
d'entre nous le compagnon de l'autre
avec les républicains nous faisons
depuis des années un choix démocratique
majeur celui de la responsabilité
je souhaite conclure en rendant hommage
à simone veil
cette grande européenne issue de notre
famille politique et qui attend un vrai
pour les droits des femmes puissent la
parole de simone veil dans son
autobiographie une vie
continuez à nous habiter venus de tous
les continents croyants et non croyants
nous appartenons tous à la même planète
à la communauté des hommes nous devons
être vigilants et la défendre non
seulement contre les forces de la nature
qui la menace mais encore davantage
contre la folie des hommes
[Applaudissements]